buddy you that fish boy from the TV  it's fish man you could unite our worlds  one day the land someone see  [Music]  something more  a hero  rated pg-13 see the new extended video  on YouTube now Aquaman is coming to  China with the fate of Atlantis at stake  there incredible battles above and below  sea and Aquaman must face not one but  two villains more like two villains must  face me dive in with us when Aquaman  hits Chinese cinema soon  [Music]  check it out  author is talking to the face  permission to come aboard Kerala means  emphasis not Anita Keitel cook is no  matter what half-brother King arm is  about to declare war on the surface  world  I came because I had no choice  you know Sakana seriously tata clay  jeanbean me taking kaiju battle action  entertainment Oh  I'll come  you